wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn from tom
bilyeu and his insane
motivation
[Music]
all right listen and listen well because
no truer words are ever going to be
spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever
it is that you decide you want to make
come true in your life
you can do that it is going to take an
inhuman amount of work you're going to
have to be prepared to break yourself in
half
you're going to have to learn more than
anyone has ever learned you're going to
have to push yourself harder than anyone
has ever
asked you to push yourself before you're
going to go way beyond your breaking
point
you're going to run until you vomit
you're going to study until you fall
asleep you're going to
push and push and push and then you're
going to push
more and when you hit the limit you're
going to push again beyond that you're
going to force yourself into an
adaptation response
and why because as malcolm x said
the future belongs to those who prepare
for it today
so if you don't put the work in today
if you don't do the unending
back breaking work of developing
yourself into something greater
the world is going to pass you by the
people that are going to own it are
going to be the ones
that did that work and the one promise
that i can make you
right now is that somebody
somebody out there is out working
somebody right now
is doing the things that i'm saying
somebody right now
is doing the work of failing
and getting up and getting better and
pushing themselves
and triggering that glorious adaptation
response that makes humans
the apex predator someone right now
they're putting in
that work and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as martin luther king jr said
if you can't fly then run if you can't
run then walk
if you can't walk then crawl but
whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
it's not okay to make excuses it's not
gonna slow people down it's not okay
to ask the world to stop so that you can
step out front
it's not okay to expect little of
yourself and
demand great rewards the only thing
that's okay is to be in line with the
way that the world
really works and if you want to be great
you've got to become capable
of greatness you've got to develop your
skill set
you've got to take what you have now and
if that's crawling then
crawl but you drag yourself ever forward
to a vision
of yourself that is so clear and so
specific
that nothing could knock you off your
path because you
my friend know exactly where you're
going you're willing to pay
whatever price it takes to get there and
no matter what anybody says no matter
how many
hecklers come for you no matter how many
people try to throw dirt on you try to
stop them try to knock you down no
matter how many
people come for you at night while you
sleep you will rise
and you will keep pushing forward and
you will get better every day and no
matter how many times people chop at you
knock you down
knock you off the path you will get back
on you will crawl so you can walk you
will walk till you run
and then you will run until you fly and
that my friends
is the only path forward so if you want
a future that makes you happy
if you want a world that you're excited
about get your ass out there and earn it
i hear people talk about luck a lot and
i know that people think about the role
that luck plays in their life
but the reality is luck is all around
luck is
ever present luck literally is coming to
you every day it's passing you by
it's happening to you right now but the
question is are you able to take
advantage of the luck
have you prepared for the luck and i
think that it comes down to we have a
misconception about what luck is
we think of luck as something as being
passive that we sit we wait we're in
some obscure place
and still somehow the luck finds us but
the reality is we're awash in luck
what we're missing is the ability to
make use of it
if you have a bunch of bullets but no
gun you really have nothing if you have
a gun but no bullets the same thing the
magic moment comes together when you
have two things that work in conjunction
and you have
them both you can't have luck without
the diligence
you can't have success without the
skills you've got to spend
your life preparing to capitalize on
that look
and to look at what somebody has done to
look at a moment of success in their
life and to say that it was
luck is to create a frame of reference
for you in which you can't see how you
yourself could leverage
what you have to get lucky so many
people
are obsessed with becoming perfect that
they never take action
and they never learn to enjoy this
moment that may be
one of the greatest tragedies any of us
can face
that right now whatever we are however
we are however good we are whatever
we've accomplished
that we fail to enjoy this moment
because we have a judgment
about who we are deep down because we
haven't acted in a way that's perfect
and i get it we have this drive it's
innate in us we want to be
great it's one of the five primary human
drivers
to pursue mastery to want to master
something and
truly be extraordinary
i understand the drive but don't let it
corrode you don't
ever do something that eats you alive
from the inside
you've got to have a vision of yourself
that allows you to morph and change and
learn from your mistakes but if you
value
perfection over learning then you're
never going to become the person that
you'd be capable of becoming
and as anna quindlin said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing
is giving up on being perfect and
beginning the work of becoming yourself
now i'm going to tell you a story and
this story pisses people off
and it goes like this my wife
who happens to be british dig it up for
england
let's say that she is with her mom
and she's in the bedroom that she grew
up in
she's all safe and sound the door is
locked
the alarm is on her mom's in the next
room making sure that she's safe
but right then a meteorite
comes screaming through the atmosphere
crashes into her bedroom and kills her
whose fault is that
i know some listen to my content
i will tell you that right now
now if people don't know me everybody
goes to it's dumb luck
divine providence it's nobody's fault
how could you blame yourself well let me
tell you how i could blame myself
and when you hear the reality of this
and you realize that i am in no way
shape or form being hyperbolic it
actually
is my fault here's why
i know right now there is an
organization that track what are called
near-earth
objects in fact i'm on the board of the
x prize
one of the prizes that they're trying to
raise money for
is for this problem to track all these
known objects and to find
some way lasers planted nuclear
explosions
something to make sure
that if something is ever on a collision
course for earth that we can stop it
literally four weekends ago
i had a chance to vote for this to say
this should be a prize
and i didn't so now
not only have i never sent a dime of my
money to help
i've never sent an email with
encouraging words
i've never called them up to tell them
what i think they should do
now i literally voted against them
so if a meteorite happens to kill my
wife
i don't have anyone to blame it myself
that's so apparently true
now i think it's the right decision i
think that putting the time and energy
into something that has such a
vanishingly slim possibility of actually
happening
makes no sense you have to know where to
put your energies all of us have a
finite amount of energy
so you at some point have to triage and
decide what are the things that i'm
going to attack
i'm far more worried about my wife
getting into a car
the likelihood of her dying is almost
certainly going to be
at this point something to do with
heart disease or
something to do with an aneurysm things
like that
it most certainly isn't going to be a
meteorite crashing
through the roof and killing her but if
it did i wouldn't waste time blaming
anyone else
now the key here the key
i wouldn't beat myself up over it i
would be crestfallen
my wife is my everything it would be a
loss so devastating i don't even want to
comprehend it
but i just wouldn't waste time blaming
anyone else
because the reality is and let this come
home
your life is the exact
reflection of the choices you have made
love your life great you've made awesome
choices
hate your life i'm sorry
you've made bad choices but the good
news is
you're in control sticking with your
good habits is extremely hard because
they're boring
so whenever something is boring it's
because somebody's pursuing something
that they actually don't give a [ __ ]
about
and that's the problem so for instance
eating healthy food all the time
is isn't
thrilling in the way that say eating a
bag of oreos
is or black licorice which is a personal
favorite of mine or fried food which is
truly my weakness that stuff is fun man
you want to talk about a dopamine
cascade i could take a random tuesday
and make it feel like a saturday night
just by deciding that i'm going to cheat
on my diet now i don't do that
i cheat maybe twice a year
so it is when i say it is crazy rare and
yet
my life is full of things that thrill
me and i use that word on purpose now
what it comes back to is going back to
the whole topic of today
habits and how you stick with them even
when you're bored even when it's not
interesting anymore
long after it stopped being fun the very
secret to habits
is caring about the thing that that
habit is meant to lead to but for real
like really what do you care about and
for instance
here is a life i pass no judgment on man
because if this is what you
want and it like you love it and you're
filled with fulfillment it's amazing
great
if you want to sit at home all day and
you want to cut your life to the
absolute quick financially so that
you're living in
um a tiny hovel with five other people
fine and you're eating tina's burritos i
don't even know if they still exist but
when i was way hardcore poor
they were awesome because it was three
for 99 cents which was amazing
so i could live off of that and you're
cool you boil it down to nothing you
don't have a car
no insurance nothing and you accept that
my life is going to be shorter than it
would otherwise be
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
smoke weed a lot and i'm going to eat
bad food
a lot man respect like if you do it with
your eyes wide open
and you're loving it and you're having a
great time it just
the only reason that you never hear me
talk about that stuff is
from my experience from what i've seen
of other people the only thing that
gives the human animal
the the best feeling which is to feel
good about yourself when you're by
yourself
is to do the hard things and to
do things that bring fulfillment and the
things that bring fulfillment are often
born of
momentary suffering but they allow you
to get stronger in order to serve other
people that's it that's just what i've
seen
so i don't think it's better than the
alternative that i just described it's
just the only thing that i've seen
really lead to that sense of like deep
fulfillment
so my thing about the the specific part
about
the good habits are hard to stick with
because they're boring just you've got
to attach
habits to things you actually really and
truly care about
no one can tell you what to care about
you can certainly build that into your
life you can take something that's an
interest and build it into something you
care deeply about
which i've talked endlessly about so i
won't go into it here but that is very
very possible
associate your habits to that thing
suddenly the habits will be very easy
don't judge yourself live your life the
way you want
but respect the realities of
neurochemistry
you've got two choices in life choice
one you can become somebody else
choice two you can become yourself now i
really
wish that there was only one choice but
in truth there's not
and most people choose to try to become
someone else because it's a road map
it's points in a direction you see
someone you respond to something you
admire them you want to be like them and
in
that process you've made your decision
in that process you've decided to become
somebody else
you have mistaken the finger for the
moon instead you need to understand that
being inspired by somebody
does not mean to become that person to
become
that which inspires you it is to
understand fundamentally
what is it about that thing that excites
you what is it what is its
essence and when you can find its
essence
then you can find out how it would apply
to you becoming
you and as zen she says
flower does not think about competing
with a flower next to it it just
blooms and that's really your job is to
see the outside world to see the flower
next to you
to understand the amazing things that
are happening all around you
all of the incredible people and the
essence of what they have
and what it is that they've done to
bring inside yourself and find out what
does that
look like when it's me not what do i
look like when i'm
them and once you understand the
difference between that then you can
really
begin to be something unique you can
become that thing that you were meant to
be that thing that makes you feel
alive and whole and that's it that's the
secret you're just trying to be
something not that's just inspiring to
other people but that you actually want
to wake up
every day and be and that's the thing
about it
there's no escaping you whatever you
become a lie the truth somebody else
yourself whatever it is
you spend every day of your
life there and as albert einstein said
everybody's a genius but if you judge a
fish by its ability to climb
a tree it will live its whole life
believing that it's stupid
and that's what confuses people people
believe that they're dumb because
they're not
finding their path they're not defining
things based on what excites them and
what they want to live with every
day they're just looking to what the
outside world says is good
and i think it's incredible that there
are other people doing things that are
so
extraordinary that we aspire to be like
that but you have to understand the
difference between being
like someone and trying to
actually beat them here's the hard truth
about getting great
their skill set to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really
find greatness those are the people that
we remember
so if you want to be remembered if you
want to achieve
real greatness you just need to have the
courage to show up every day
and take another swing take another
photo
try another task do something that
scares you
and do those little things over and over
and over until you win the only thing
you have to believe in
lean close hear my words
the only thing you have to believe in
right now
is that humans are capable
of learning that humans for whatever
reason
nature has chosen to not endow us with a
whole bunch of like
pre-programmed things so for instance a
baby horse a foal
i believe is how you say that when
they're born they can already walk
literally boom they come out and they're
walking and all is well because that's
all hardwired into them
but a horse is a horse is a horse and
they're going to stay a horse and that's
that
and you're never going to find a horse
reading chaucer just not going to happen
so that's all those decisions are
pre-wired
humans on the other hand come out they
cannot take care of themselves they're a
lump of flesh
they basically know how to suckle and
that's sort of the extent of it
but now humans have the ability to go in
all these
crazy different directions and they can
learn to
become an astrophysicist they can learn
to become a carpenter a doctor
an astronaut like the number of
directions that humans can go in is
crazy
the amount of what was once known as
junk dna we now know is epigenetic
signaling
the way that we can respond in all these
different directions to
our environment to the things we choose
to focus our energies on is is
truly unique to humans is just
absolutely astonishing
so understanding that that's baked into
the human animal is the ability to learn
and go in any direction so once you
realize that humans are adaptation
machines that we can learn
anything now it's like okay whatever you
want to do you can do it as long as
you're willing to pay that price i'm not
saying that it's not going to be hard it
is going to be
very very hard i'm just saying that it
is doable and that you will receive a
return on investment in your energies
and that's what people need to know and
believe to the core of their being
that my time in this direction will be
rewarded
now here's where people [ __ ] themselves
up there is this
[ __ ] debate about whether or not
it is hey am i pre-programmed i'm good
at math and so
that's it and i should go do things that
are math or i'm good at verbal and i
should go do things that are verbal i'm
naturally gifted as an athlete so i
should go be an athlete
look i'm not saying people don't get
early wins people get early wins and if
you
happen to love the thing you're getting
early wins and that's awesome man
and you'll find it just a little bit
easier you've got a headwind or a
tailwind i guess a tailwind you have a
tailwind
um and so that yeah love that but if
they're
the thing that gives you the most energy
in life
is something that you have no natural
inclinations for
then go learn that when i say that i
have
zero zero natural ability as an
entrepreneur i mean
zero i had to learn everything
from not being lazy to problem solving
to overcoming my paralyzing fear to look
at world like
a puzzle dealing with anxiety literally
it it was comical as i was going down my
journey in the beginning as an
entrepreneur
to figure this [ __ ] out
it's ridiculous and then i meet people
who are like ripping flowers out of
people's front yards and
selling them back to them like when i
say that that was not me
i had a paper route and i was so chicken
to go up to people's doors
that i actually only got half the money
that i could have gotten for the same
paper route the same amount of effort
but because i was so afraid to go knock
on people's doors and ask to collect the
money that was due
that for like two years i did a paper
out for half the money okay that's how
[ __ ] of an entrepreneur i was when i
started
so you can learn this stuff now my goals
demanded that i learn entrepreneurship
so i learned it so that's what i want
people to understand
what is your goal work backwards from
there
if it lines up with what you're
naturally good at that's amazing and
congratulations but there are going to
be times where it doesn't line up
and you've just got to either change
your goal
or recognize that i'm going to have to
figure these things out and
because i'm an adaptation machine as a
human being i can do
all of that your talent and intelligence
are not fixed they're malleable
so you suck at skateboarding because
you're afraid of pain
so the only thing you need to know right
now
the point is not to avoid the pain and
you need to
stop asking yourself what's the least
you can do to get good
and you need to start asking yourself
what's the most you can bear
to become great once you understand the
whole point is to let the suffering and
the pain harden you
into becoming the version of yourself
that you need to become in order to
execute at the highest level to be world
class at anything
and stop avoiding it stop being afraid
of it and start understanding for what
it really
is which is the thing that shapes you so
my entire youth
i feared pain i moved away from pain if
something was
emotionally or physically difficult i
avoided it and i remember being in the
gym one day and going
will you stop asking like what's the
least you need to do to consider it a
full week workout
because it was like could i stop now
could i stop now could i stop now and i
was like do you want the muscles
or do you want to like put on a show
that you showed up like you showed up
right
like because the muscles demand what the
muscles demand like
you have to break them down you have to
push you have to do more like so
it is purely a question of how much
you're willing to bear
because there's never going to be enough
you could have always done more
as shakespeare noted there's nothing
good or bad but thinking makes it so
there's nothing good or bad right
there's just stimulus and then there's
response
things happen right but people think
that it is objectively a certain way so
now because they think it is an object
objectively a certain way they feel they
are supposed to react
based on those emotions that are getting
kicked up in their mind
what i'm saying is absolutely not those
emotions may not serve you
they're certainly not aimed at moving
you towards your goal their job is to
keep you alive plain and simple
so that's not necessarily very helpful
in a modern context so if you want to
always be moving towards your goal you
want to be optimized you got to learn to
get control of your emotions
you've got to learn to understand to
tell yourself a narrative that isn't
predicated on necessarily identifying
what is objectively true
because i don't think that we experience
the world that way it's identifying
what's going to work
to get me to my goal and that to me like
my whole thing is goal first everything
else works backwards from that
like starting from the like the grand
strategy like identifying it and then
building the steps backwards to reverse
engineering essentially
correct we talk of self-esteem in one of
two ways
either as the sole determinant of
success
or as the ultimate enemy most people
build their self-esteem around their
accomplishments
they feel good about themselves if
they're making the most money they're
dating the hottest person
or they've built the best product they
get caught in the rat race
of validating themselves against the
person who happens to be standing next
to them
but there's a fundamental flaw with this
equation because
when your ego is that attached to your
success
it's devastated by your failures and
what
the most successful people know is you
cannot
leave your self-worth in the hands of
anyone else
the most successful people get their
pride from a different
source one that does not fluctuate with
their successes and failures
so i knew i couldn't give up my
self-esteem i couldn't accept some weird
role where i just
was always the dumb ass sitting in the
corner if i pride myself on being smart
and you tell me i'm dumb
and you put up a pretty good case for it
that's going to damage my self-esteem
my self-esteem in that situation is very
fragile
if on the other hand you tell me that
i'm dumb
and i build my self-esteem around being
the learner
now i'm gonna say thank you please tell
me in what way that i'm dumb
because you will open my eyes to
something that now i can address
and i can go learn about that thing and
i will have a new skill
and i can go out and push and execute
against that skill one of the most
powerful things that you could do
is become the person that admits that
you're wrong
really fast and it's crazy how much
credibility you'll earn with people
simply by admitting
i was wrong like 30 seconds ago i was
fighting so hard for something
i was really fighting for my position
and then somebody says something and i
realized
that's actually better imagine that the
more you try to tell me i'm dumb the
more areas that you point out that i'm
weak the more things you tell me i need
to learn about
my eyes are open to something that if
true i'm going to go down that path and
i'm going to learn how to do that
and that is absolutely critical as
martin luther said
even if i knew that tomorrow the world
would go to pieces
i would still plant my apple tree some
things you
build whether you can control the
outcome or not sometimes it's the
process
that is the thing that's meant to be
enjoyed it's the process
that you're meant to invest in and
rather than always thinking about the
goal
the outcome or what you're going to get
out of something
focus on the something focus on the part
of it that you can control
because you can't always control the
outcome you can't know what's going to
happen tomorrow tomorrow is not
guaranteed to any of us
and yet we all act and yet we create
momentum in our lives when we're at our
best
but we do that not because we can
control every aspect we do that because
we accept
that there are things that we cannot
control and as steve maraboli said
incredible change happens in your life
when you decide to take control of what
you do have power over
instead of craving control over what you
don't
and that's where a lot of people get
lost they focus not on what they have in
their hands they focus instead on the
things that they can't control
it irritates them it frustrates them
it's like a splinter in their mind they
can't stop thinking about the things
that they don't have control over
and they're blinded to the incredible
wealth that is around them of things
that they could enjoy
right here right now
that's why gratitude is such an
empowering practice to sit there and not
think of the glorious things
may await you in your future but rather
to think about the things you have here
in this moment
oxygen in your lungs a simple breeze on
your face
a window in your house someone that you
love someone that loves you
nothing that costs money nothing that
was the pot of gold at the end of a
glorious rainbow
it's not even about becoming something
extraordinary and waiting for the
results of that
it's simply understanding that the one
thing you can control are your actions
today the choices that you make what you
get to do how you
think about yourself the beliefs you
choose to bring into your life
those things you control and when you
understand the power in
acknowledging that control and taking
control and using
it that's when your life is going to
begin to change but first
you have to divorce yourself from being
obsessively interested only in an
outcome if instead you build
your self-esteem you build your pride on
pursuit
you build your pride on allowing
yourself to care about something so
deeply that even though tomorrow is not
guaranteed that you're going to plant
your apple tree today
that you're going to love that process
because it is the thing you can control
you can control how you show
up you can control how you play you
cannot control how other people
react you cannot control what they think
about you
but you can control what you think about
yourself you can earn credibility with
yourself you can control what you do
and when you take full ownership of that
and realize that your life is an exact
reflection of
your choices of the things you could
control and what you did with them
then everything begins to change you're
not looking to blame somebody else
you're not even worried about anybody
else
you're just asking one simple question
what can i do right now regardless of
tomorrow
to improve my life today
focus there and you'll enjoy every
day of your life as confucius said
when it's obvious that the goal cannot
be reached
don't adjust the goals adjust the action
steps
that may be the single best piece of
advice you're ever
going to get write that down burn it
into your flesh
tattoo it on your soul do whatever you
need to do to remember that
once you set a goal once you've decided
in your life there is something that
you're going to make come true don't let
anything stop you from reaching that
but the reality is as you go things are
going to get in your way there will be
an inevitable
slew of obstacles coming at you
but when it gets so hard that you
realize that the path that you're on is
simply not going to take you where you
want to go
rather than give up on what it was you
said you were going to do
find a different path and in that when
you really
make that the cornerstone of your
identity that you refuse to bend or be
broken
by obstacles by challenges but instead
you rise to those challenges
you go over under through them you do
whatever you have to you devise any plan
to find
a way through
then your life will change once that
becomes your reaction to not
change that thing that meant so much to
you that you've dedicated your life to
making it come true that you don't
change that but rather you find another
way you tap into your creativity you
find somebody that can help you you do
whatever it takes to get on the other
side of that you do whatever it takes
to build that life that you want to see
but if your reaction is to change your
goal
to make it easier to move it closer to
be less
of who you could be simply so you can
check a box
you're never going to have anything
that's worth having we get to decide
who we are there's no objective truth
that you're going to find or uncover
you're simply the collection of the
things that you believe to be true
about yourself and once you begin to
form that opinion of who you are
you'll act in accordance with that
belief you begin to shape a vision
of yourself in your own mind and that
becomes the reality so letting other
people
influence that letting other people come
in and degrade what you think of
yourself
is one of the most dangerous and damning
things that you could do because they
cloud your ability to
craft to craft a vision
of the person that you want to become
and that vision is so
hard for all of us to hold on to that we
have to protect it we have to keep
other people out of that we've got to
have intention
in creating the person that we want to
become i don't think people really
realize
we construct our lives we build them
from nothing we decide what our goals
are we decide in what way to move
we decide who we're going to become and
what we're going to get
but it's a decision it's a process it
isn't something that somebody hands to
you
and so if you find that your life is a
misery understand that your life is an
exact
reflection of your choices and if you
want a different life you need only make
a different choice
but i know right now many of you are
thinking but i don't know what way
to go i don't know what choice to make i
don't know what it is
that i want to do and as roy maurice
keane said
i don't believe skill was or ever will
be the result of coaches
it is a result of a love affair between
the child
and the ball so ask yourself
what's that thing that you love and
don't judge yourself if it was something
that you loved as a child that people
are telling you you couldn't possibly
make money and it's that part of the
equation that i want to break for people
i want you to understand
stop asking yourself what you can make a
lot of money yet and start asking
yourself what would you enjoy
what is that life that you don't need to
escape from what is the life
that is your love what is the thing that
as a kid you did
whether people wanted you to or not what
is the thing you would sneak out at
night to do
because you weren't going to be stopped
from doing it everybody has something
like that in their life
some spark of interest may be long
dormant maybe that they have pushed
aside
because they think it's stupid or maybe
they failed once
and they think they're bad at it even
though they love it
that sting of the failure has convinced
him to stop pursuing it
but at the end of the day the only thing
that matters is what gives you that
energy
at the end of the day the thing that
matters is what fills you with joy
at the end of the day the only thing
that matters it's not success
and it sure as hell isn't money
it's how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself it's the things that
give you energy
it's what you think about yourself it's
how you react to the hard things it's
whether or not you push through
and when you push through when you
persevere when you go down the process
of taking the time to structure
your life to build it into something
that you want it to be
to build it into something that you're
proud of to become the person that's
capable of the things you want to do
that can first fall in love with
something and do it for the love of it
not worry about what other people think
if you hate your life i guarantee you
the thing is that you are trapped by
what other people think
you don't want to give it up because
somebody will think you're a failure you
don't want to give it up
because it's a paycheck you don't want
to give it up because you're scared
you're scared you don't know what you'll
do next
but imagine a world for a second where
all you thought about was what do you
love
what do you enjoy in that moment it
doesn't matter if it changes from day to
day
just what do you love what fills you
with joy what gives you that energy at
the end of the day the only thing that
we all have is right now this moment
it's what you're experiencing loving
what you do how you spend your time
that's the point of all of it the point
of life
is that in each transient moment that
passes by
doing something that fills you with joy
nobody can give you that
you've got to build that life
so go out figure out what it is that you
want to do
and brick by brick have the courage
to build that life as henry rollins said
i don't have talent so i just get up
earlier
the thing that people think about
becoming great
about doing the extraordinary is that
it's just meant for some people and not
meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary
as a way to let themselves off the hook
because if somebody is just
gifted if they were blessed by god if
they were touched by an angel
and they just have something that you
don't and something that you never will
have
then it's fine for them to be great and
you to be ordinary
but the reality is it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate
natural talent that if somebody is
graced by god that if they have
something divine about them that they're
somehow
better that it's more beautiful than the
scrappy person who's had to work for
everything
they've ever had the guy who simply
acknowledges like henry rollins that he
doesn't have more talent than the next
person
he's simply willing to out work them
he's willing to set the alarm to get up
to do whatever it takes to find his path
to create that skill
to out work talent to show that by
putting in that energy
and that effort there's a magnification
effect that is far greater than
anything that could be given to you
bestowed upon you you have to grab it
you have to take it
you have to have a level of intensity in
your life
to be able to leverage it and create
something amazing
and as warren buffett said intensity is
the price of excellence
if you want to be great you've got to
cultivate that intensity you've got to
understand it's not about what you were
born with it's not about what you were
given where you started or even where
you're going
it is entirely about what you plant at
the center of your soul
how hard you're willing to go after
something how
much focus you're willing to put in your
life and how often you come back to that
level of intensity
for who you want to be
[Music]
because if you want to be excellent
you will have to pay a price and that
price is eternal vigilance
vigilance over how you spend your time
vigilance over the demands you make of
yourself
vigilance over what you allow yourself
to think and believe
and when you get to the point that you
only allow yourself to think and believe
things and move you towards your goals
that every day the actions you take are
things that are designed to get you
there
and that you have the intensity to
follow that through to shape yourself
to create a new version of you capable
of doing
something extraordinary then your life
is going to be what you want
but not until then it's never going to
be anything if you just make other
people extraordinary and say i could
never do that
but the reality is you could and you're
just not
so the thing you have to face right now
is that it
is within your grasp
you just have to go after it everything
around you
is incredible if you're willing to look
at it that way
everything around you can be taken for
granted if that's your perspective
but it really is about the frame that
you choose to put around things
i mean simply being alive is already
insane the odds are
so stacked against you not only just
being a human but being a human at this
moment in time this moment in time where
breakthroughs and technology are
happening at
an unprecedented rate where
breakthroughs in medical science are
happening at an unprecedented rate
where our ability to connect with people
to empathize with people all the way
around the globe
all of the changes that have happened in
technology and telecom and connectivity
health everything we're living
in the most miraculous time ever
but you have to look at it that way and
as joseph campbell said
life is a wonderful wonderful opera
except that it hurts so the question is
do you see it as the beautiful opera
or do you just pay attention to the pain
and at the end of the day you're going
to get what you focus on they're both
true this is both the most amazing time
that's ever happened
ever in recorded history and yet real
things that are terrifying are also
happening
but where you put your energy where you
put your
attention where you put your focus is
going to determine what you see
and that is the most fascinating and the
most important thing you have to
understand
about the way that your mind works you
get what you focus on if you focus on
the things that are bad they will become
real
they will become exaggerated they will
begin to monopolize your thoughts you'll
see them everywhere
it's called the reticular activating
system your mind is literally designed
to pay attention to the things that you
notice
once you notice a certain car you see it
everywhere once you notice a certain dog
you see it everywhere once you
hear a certain name for the first time
suddenly realize that that name has been
all around you this entire time but now
that you're focusing on it now that
you're looking for it
it is everywhere so whatever you look
for
it's going to be everywhere if you look
for the negative it'll be there but if
you look for the positive
it will overwhelm you as kurt vonnegut
one of the
greatest authors in modern times said
when i write i feel like an armless
legless man with a crayon in his mouth
but he still did it and that's the kind
of thing that you're going to hear from
the greats you're not going to hear that
it was easy you're not going to hear
that they felt suave and cool
even the greatest of all time have that
awkwardness that clumsiness they're
never quite as good as they want to be
but what i want you to understand is
even though kurt vonnegut said those
words
he wrote tons of books
that changed people's lives that changed
the landscape of literature because
despite
the fact that he felt awkward and clumsy
he kept
doing it and doing it and forcing
himself to move forward
to take one step after another even when
the process
was not exactly rewarding he believed in
something
he knew that what he was trying to do
would ultimately
get better he knew that if he wanted to
accomplish
something great that he had to push
through the awkwardness and
that is the very trick to getting great
you just have to do it you have to go
you have to take that first step you
have to push you have to drive you have
to strive
every time to get a little bit better
you have to strive
not to fall prey to your own doubts and
insecurities
and as joe namath said if you aren't
going all the way why go at all
as haroon yaya noted i always wonder why
birds stay in the same place when they
can fly anywhere on earth
and then i ask myself the same question
as mark twain put it the secret of
getting ahead is getting started
and that's where people get stuck you're
literally like the bird you could fly
anywhere you want you can go anywhere
you want to go and look i know you've
got a litany of excuses and
all of them are valid you've got a job
you can't just leave or you don't have a
job and you don't have the money
your family is in one place it's the
only thing that you've ever known
you only speak one language you've never
traveled before you don't have a
passport
you can't afford the gas money there are
a thousand
real reasons not to go
but the truth is that none of them
matter the truth is if you want to build
something in your life that you have to
remember
what mark twain said you have to get
started because at the end of the day
that is
literally the only thing that's holding
you back you're not moving
and once you get the simplicity of that
once you understand
that you could act right now you could
say all the excuses you could stop
making them you could stop giving in to
them no matter how
valid they are no matter how real they
may seem
you can finally decide that you're going
to get up a move that you're going to
create that momentum that you're going
to take a step that you're going to make
the demand
that you create momentum that you get
something done that you
find an answer or as hannibal said that
you're going to find a way or
make one if you have to carve through
rock do it
because humans before you have done it
and that's the simple truth that is the
simple truth
and everything else is [ __ ]
everything else
is the weak voice in your mind holding
you back
and making you a less version of
yourself so i ask you
why doesn't the bird fly wherever it
wants to go
because that's all it's known because
that's what's safe
because that's what's comfortable or
because it's a dumb
animal what do you want to be
if this isn't the life you want to live
do something about it as ralph waldo
emerson said
we're all inventors each sailing out on
a voyage of discovery guided each by a
private chart
of which there is no duplicate
we're all lost at sea we're all on this
grand adventure
but the punchline is we have no idea
where we're going
and the map that we have is private only
to us and it's
quite frankly blank and it's about
filling it in
it's about learning where you are it's
about finding
guideposts and beginning to build this
map only from that which you've done and
so you have to go
blindly forward and the only thing
that's going to give you the courage to
step into that abyss to step into the
truly unknown
into the dangerous world before you
truly into a sea
of infinite peril the only thing that's
going to give you the courage
to do that is that you can learn
that you'll figure it out it's not going
to be easy it's going to be hard and at
times it is
truly going to be life-threatening but
that is the nature of life
and as you're out there in the
wilderness as you're out there lost at
sea
all you have to do is remember two
things
it is an adventure and adventures are
never safe
but the rewards of an adventure are the
discovery of something entirely new
and two you can do it you
can do it the very fact that you're a
human gives you the ability to process
your surroundings to figure things out
to go in and fumble around you're not
going to look good
you're going to drink a ton of ocean
water and it is going to suck and you're
going to be vomiting over the sides and
it is going to be difficult there are
going to be times
where you're convinced you're going to
drown
but if in those moments you stay
clear-headed and you focus on
getting better you focus on the
adventure
you don't worry about the outcome you
just focus on right now in this moment
with everything going wrong what can i
learn to calm yourself
and to remember right there if you're
panicking you're asking the wrong
question
if you're panicking you're asking
questions about how you look you're
asking questions about how this is going
to end up
if you want to kill your panic in any
moment ask yourself
right then and there what can i learn
what can i learn from this
life is nothing but practice and as long
as you keep that in mind as long as you
understand it's never performance it's
always
practice it's simply an opportunity to
learn and get better then you can
reframe the entire
ordeal that you're going through and as
paolo cuello said
people are capable at any time in their
lives of doing what they dream of
but it's only going to come true through
that process of learning and discovery
and putting yourself out there and going
into the unknown but if you're never
willing to step
off because all you can see are the
problems all you can see are the things
that could
go wrong then you never get the chance
to learn
but the way that humans learn is through
engagement it's through
interacting and if you don't dare
to do that if you don't dare to step out
into the unknown and to flounder around
and look stupid and embarrass yourself
then you're never going to grow and if
you never grow then you're never going
to make your dreams come true
so if you have that dream locked inside
of you know that the only way to get it
out is to
risk to dare to strive
to try to grow to grope
to fall to fail
to learn and ultimately succeed
that's the only way that dreams come
true greatness is
the most demanding mistress you're ever
going to encounter and i understand the
advice that i'm about to give you
is not for everyone most people
should turn this off but if you're gonna
stick with me if you're going to
listen to what i have to say it's
because you want something tremendous in
your life
you want to stand out from everyone else
you want to do something
more than other people think is possible
you literally
want to stand outside the norm and if
that's
the case for you then understand
that as albert einstein said only one
who devotes himself to a cause with his
whole strength and soul
can be a true master for this reason
mastery demands all of a person
if you want to get great if you really
want
to make a skill set your own if you want
to be able to do something and at the
end of the day
if you want to transform the world if
you want to make grand
changes if you want to do all of that
all the empty words that people spout
all the time let me tell you
the only thing that's going to separate
you from all the other blowhards who are
just talking words
and will never do anything
is to give yourself over completely to
let that obsession let that thing that
you love
completely consume you and in that
your only chance to really become great
lies
here's the harsh reality you're just not
good enough yet
as brian tracy said your true success in
life begins
only when you make the commitment to
become excellent at what you do
this is the gap that i see in most
people's lives
they've not yet made the commitment to
become extraordinary
and the reason that they haven't made
that commitment yet is they don't
believe that they can
they're afraid of what it might take to
get there they
just don't want it enough that's the
reality
most people don't want it enough to face
all of that they don't want to face
their inadequacies they don't want to
accept that they're going to have to go
through that process that
gut-wrenching back-breaking process of
becoming
great and every day lulls them into this
sense that there's always time to do it
tomorrow but the reality is there is
only now
there is only today and if you really
want to do something with your life that
leaves your own jaw on the floor that
leaves
you in awe of what you've done
you're going to have to admit you're not
yet good enough
you've got to put in that work that
you've got to develop
a set of skills that simply can't be
denied but if you do that
on the other side of getting that good
at falling in love with something and
working so hard that you can feel
yourself
changing as a human being on the other
side of that
is something unimaginably beautiful
and as les brown said if you set goals
and go after them with
all the determination you can muster
your gifts will take you places
that will amaze you that's what i want
in my life and i hope that's what you
want in yours is to be amazed
to be amazed at how extraordinary this
life really is
this opportunity to make of yourself
anything you want to be really think
about that for a second you can become
anything you want to become you can
become an astronaut a world-class
athlete a musician the best parent
that this world has ever seen anything
you want is yours for the taking
but it takes effort it takes
a willingness to stare nakedly at your
inadequacies it takes a willingness to
really gut check yourself
about where you are today and it doesn't
mean that you can't go and be something
better tomorrow
and falling in love with that process
that knowing that being a human and
really getting the most
out of your potential is that to know
that tomorrow i can be better than i am
today and that doesn't
make you a bad person today
it's okay to know that you can be better
tomorrow and still love yourself
today but it's also okay to love
yourself today
and demand that you get better tomorrow
and once you can do that there is
literally
nowhere you can't go as buckminster
fuller said
there's nothing in a caterpillar that
tells you that it's going to be a
butterfly
and welcome to the human condition
that's the truth of what it's like to be
a person you're hoping that you turn
inward and see
some sign some glimmer some gift that
you have that's been bestowed upon you
that you were born with that is your
very
birthright but there's nothing you were
born hopelessly average
and the sooner that you accept that the
sooner that you accept that you were no
better than anyone that came before you
and everyone that's going to come after
you but all of us
have potential and so the question
becomes the question you have to answer
with your very life the question
that your actions will answer
what are you going to do with that
potential will you actuate it will you
bust your ass to get good will you get
so
good over time that you can play with
the greats will you get
so good that people look at you with awe
can you get so good that you become the
excuse
that other people use not to try can you
get so good
that people have to dismiss you as
naturally talented can you get
so good that people refuse to believe
that they can get that good can you work
so hard
gaining a set of skills and driving
yourself day after day to get better
never accepting who you are always
pushing yourself forward always
demanding more
and seeing the beauty and what you can
become and knowing that even today
as a caterpillar with nothing
with nothing to indicate you'll become a
butterfly can you become
the butterfly through sheer force of
will
because if you can become that you
become a beacon of hope not for
other people for yourself because you
proved that there really are no
limits and as walt disney said you may
not realize it when it happens but a
kick in the teeth
may be the best thing in the world for
you why
because it's the thing that's going to
make you react it's the thing that's
going to hold you down it's the thing
that is going to make you say
never again no more i refuse to accept
this about myself i refuse to accept
that i'm average
i refuse to accept that i can't be
something more i refuse
to stop when something kicks me in the
teeth i refuse to stop when people hate
on me or tell me that i can't do
something
i refuse to be dictated to by anyone
even my own potential i refuse
to be held back by anything least of all
me
as oprah winfrey said what you dwell on
is what you become
once you understand that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine and you
understand that the brain
actually builds faster and better
connections between the things you think
on you will begin to understand
that it is incredibly important
to be thoughtful about what you think
about it's incredibly important to
pick a direction that you want to grow
in to decide
who you want to become and then make
that the center of your focus your
thoughts your time your energy
and if you look inward or if you look
outward and you don't like what you see
remember what jim rohn said if you don't
like how things are
change it you're not a tree and that's
the beauty
that's the beautiful thing about being a
human we are so plastic and we can
change so dramatically we are
so good at adapting that we forget
that's literally what we do but if you
can take control of that process
if you can grab a hold of it and make it
your own if you can make it your daily
obsession to
make the most of your potential to pick
a very specific direction to pick
an end goal an end state an end identity
and work your way backwards
find out the steps that you're going to
need to take to get there to execute and
have
the willingness to put in the work to
have the willingness to be both the
sculptor
and the clay to understand that the
suffering that comes with that of
changing yourself of making yourself
into something great
is a suffering well worth it it's a
suffering
that you should embrace it's a suffering
that you should run towards because in
that suffering you can become
any thing you want
so start to dwell on that dwell on a
vision of
you being great dwell on a vision of you
accomplishing your goals
dwell on a vision of you having done
this amazing thing that you want to do
dwell on an image of you being willing
to sweat and bend yourself in half
and break if need to and bleed when
necessary to become
the vision of yourself you always knew
you could become
dwell on that and nothing can stop you
now if you don't know this quote live by
it one can have no smaller or greater
mastery than mastery over oneself that's
da vinci
da vinci did amazing things with his
life i wanted to do equally amazing
things with mine
and if that's the game that we're
playing if i can construct my belief
system if i can choose at any moment
to believe something that's more
empowering
than i was believing the moment before
and that that
will actually find its way into my
actions
allow me to do things that i couldn't do
the moment before
then it's like that moment in the matrix
where nia realizes
he knows kung fu and that's like
as funny as that is that's how i think
about life to me
the very fundamental purpose of life
is to find out how many skills
i can acquire that have utility
and then put that utility to the test in
service of something greater than myself
how many skills can i acquire that have
utility put that utility
to the test in service of something
greater than myself that is for me the
purpose of life now i don't actually
want to know kung fu
that is not the mission that i'm here to
live but i knew that i had to identify
my mission so what was going to be my
mission
mother teresa has an amazing quote
nobody will act for the many
but people will act for the one
and that really struck me because i
realized they were right
i was looking at this global pandemic of
ill health
and i wasn't moving into action
but thinking about my mom and my sister
or the uncle i had who ate himself to
death when i was 12 years old
that made me want to act i remember this
was a piece of advice that my
father-in-law gave me
that i promptly ignored and don't worry
i've since apologized to him
and very much adopted this mentality
but he said the most important thing in
business is to know more about
the topic than anybody else in the room
and if you don't see an echo of that in
my preparation
for the interviews and i'm not doing a
good job of explaining it
that was something that when he said it
i am so sad to report that it did not
hit me
but for whatever weird reason it really
stuck with me and it was one of those
things that i thought about and thought
about and thought about
and then it finally manifested itself
and me realizing that to get good at
anything
whether that's business whether that's
interviewing it really is that level of
preparation
it is about going above and beyond to
get good at something and i was thinking
about this last night at the event
and there's always like a thousand
questions that i get asked about how you
build a business
you know whatever your dream is how do
you go and actually manifest it and
the honest answer to everything is get
better get better and i've had really
talented
artists begin reaching out to me on
instagram because obviously that's a
huge focus for us and the next phase is
going to be
getting writers getting artists
bringing them together creating amazing
comic books in phase one
and they'll have like a really small
following and they'll say you know like
what what am i doing wrong what's the
secret
and the truth is even though they're
really good
they've got to get a lot better and when
you can be
world class but admit that you're not
yet
undeniable cause there's unfortunately a
lot of people that are world class like
think about it you make it to the
olympics your whole life you've been
busting your ass you finally make it
you're one of the best in your country
truly a world-class player but you
come in seventh eighth
it's you haven't gotten to the point
where you're so good that you can't be
ignored and
that like in today's world where
social media rules everything and anyone
can get on there create noise
you've got to find a way to cut through
the clutter and the way to cut through
the clutter one of there's more and i
will recommend perennial seller by
our boy ryan holliday really interesting
book
really excited i think we've booked him
for like november
that'll be a lot of fun but is in his
book he talks about
several of the other things you're going
to do but i'll say that the most
important one
is to get so good that you you cannot be
ignored
cannot be ignored so if you're being
ignored by the way the world has told
you
that you've not yet gotten to where you
want to get to so
everybody knows my obsession with disney
read the disney biography
in times of trouble disney always came
back around to make
the product better make the product
better this is somewhere that i think a
lot of people get lost is they don't
spend any effort making sure that the
thing that they're doing with their life
is actually something that generates
excitement it builds excitement it gives
to them more than it takes now
it doesn't mean i'm not exhausted at the
end of my days
i am really tired but
i am having a ball
i'm having a ball it's fun i believe in
what i'm doing i'm excited
by what i'm doing and so that's where
you should be spending the vast majority
of your times
but that's all stuff about striving to
do more to be more i'm excited
to acquire the skills i'm excited to
push myself it isn't a dark and dingy
place like i'm legitimately amped up to
do it
and that's what i want people to
understand like i'm
the amount of hours that i work the
hardcore way that i'm driven the
overwhelming majority of that energy
comes from a place of excitement it
comes from a place of being enthusiastic
about what i'm doing
there is 20 it's the dark side i
leverage it it is a real thing for me
and it helps me in those acute moments
when for whatever reason the excitement
just isn't enough at that moment
then i will think about the people who
wish me ill then i will think about the
things that are dragging me down then i
will focus on the inadequacies
in my life and that i demand that i get
better at those things 100
but it's an 80 20 split you've got to
learn balance that split you've got to
put something that you give a [ __ ] about
at the center of your life that is so
so so important never give up
on what you really want to do the person
with big dreams
is more powerful than the person with
all the facts
h jackson brown truer words have never
been spoken it is one of the most
interesting things about the human
condition that all of the facts in the
world no matter how true something may
objectively really be the only thing
that matters
is whether or not you've got the energy
to see through to the end of what you
want to do
and the energy comes not from truth
the energy comes from your dream the
energy comes from what it is that you
want to do
the energy ultimately is born out of
what you want to create
it's born out of a willingness
to allow yourself to dream it's born out
of a willingness to think that you
actually can do it
it's born out of a willingness to take
that first step
but the only reason that you're going to
take that first step is you believe that
you can actually make your dreams come
true and that
sense of this thing that you have in
your mind that you can make it real that
you can bring it into the real world and
have that excitement that you've long
fantasized about and understand and
really feel
in your gut that that thing
that you've dreamed about can be real
and when you have that that's when
you're going to have the energy that you
need to push
and to fight and to go through all of
the difficult things that you're gonna
have to to get on the other side and
make that dream real as
ferdinand foch said the most powerful
weapon
on earth is the human soul on fire
but the human soul can't be on fire
without a dream a human soul
is not fed by facts a human soul is fed
instead by a belief that it can
accomplish what it wants to accomplish
it's fed by that thing that idea that
you've had in your mind that you fanned
those flames of interest
and turned it into a real fascination
and fan those flames further
into excitement and allowed yourself to
truly embody
that belief that you can make it happen
so right now whatever it is whatever
crazy dream you have and we all have one
stop
judging yourself for it stop telling
yourself that you can't do it and
understand
when you cultivate that fire when you
take that little ember and you
fan it into a raging inferno that that
thing
that human stole on fire is what's going
to allow you to
build something that the world has never
seen before
but it starts with that dream it starts
with your willingness to cultivate that
to think about it to allow yourself to
do that because so
many people stop themselves they think
they're inadequate they think that they
could never do it
and even if that is a fact
it's not something that's going to help
you live a life that excites you
it's not something that's going to help
you excite other people
the one thing that will do that is the
dream
so right now allow yourself that
simply to dream when i hear people where
their reaction is to
about a problem like let you and i were
talking you being hispanic
is working against you jason you being
an african-american it's working against
you
like you're gonna have to go uphill but
now what you're gonna sit and complain
about it
because it won't help you right so if
you have a goal it's like it does suck
that women have to work harder to get to
the same place that as a white male in
america that i have to get to
but if it is true if we're all going to
accept that it's true
we can all sit there and go we need to
focus on the systems
fair enough and i'm glad that some
people do that the other option though
is to say well i completely control me
and the one thing i will tell any human
being alive right now
there is always room for the best
and once you're able through your skills
that have utility
to move somebody else closer to their
goal you will become a hot commodity
no matter what no matter what
okay think about the scientists what
were the scientists after world war ii
right before they were scientists for us
they were nazis but we were
way happy to let go of that because they
had crazy skills that we needed right
so really what it comes down to is what
are your skills
like if you've got skills that can be
used to build something beautiful to do
something wonderful
to the world to help people move towards
their goals that will excite the masses
because they
they want that thing that you're going
to create that it's going to improve
people's lives
but only thing that mattered in all of
that was you got really good at
something
and somewhere along the way we lost that
the punch line is
no matter what you do to the system you
you
as an individual need to get
extraordinary
at something and so my encouragement to
people is
go get extraordinary like don't worry
about whether the system is broken or
not
we built quest a billion dollar company
in less than five years coming out of
the great recession
so more what was it in the
great depression more millionaires were
created in the great depression than any
other time in history
it's like it just comes down to somebody
goes
honestly this is how i react the system
is too big and complicated i'm too
afraid
to try to get caught up in fixing that
i'm too big of a chicken there i just
said it
i'm too big of a chicken to deal with
that but i can deal with myself
i can go get extraordinary right so
focus on that go get extraordinary go
become the best
of whatever it is you want to be but go
become the best
of it and see how the world opens to you
and as bruce lee said
if you always put limits on everything
you do physical or
anything else it will spread into your
work and into your life there are no
limits there are only plateaus and you
must not
stay there you must go beyond them
even in the statement you can see him
making the choice about what to believe
by saying that there are no limits
by taking something that other people
perceive as a limit as something that's
stopping him and saying that's not it's
a plateau it's something that i can push
through
and you see what he holds himself
accountable to
it's not okay to stay at a plateau it's
okay to have one everybody has them they
happen it's
a natural part of the course of getting
better but it is not okay
to stay there and that is a choice
that's not something anyone can hand you
it's something you have to believe to
the core of your soul that it is not
okay to stay in a plateau and it's that
that's gonna push you through it's that
that's gonna make you get up and keep
going
but first you have to recognize that
life is cause and effect you have to
recognize that that choice is a knock on
effect
you have to recognize that him merely
saying those words out loud
have a cause and effect they change the
course
of his life the expectations that other
people have of him expectations that he
has of himself
and because he understands that he can
control the outside world by first
controlling what's inside by changing
his belief system to match what he wants
to accomplish
he's then able to accomplish
what he did in his life had nothing to
do with luck it had everything to do
with the demands that he made on himself
it had to do with when he got in a
motorcycle accident people told him he
would never walk again
not only did he walk again all of the
major accomplishments that we think
about of being that man
they all came after they came after he
was told he was never going to walk
came after he was told that he was never
going to be able to do martial arts but
he did it
he did the grueling work of getting
better he understood cause and effect he
understood that if he chose to believe
that he could never do it that he'd
never be able to do it
but that if he chose to believe that by
working out he could get stronger and
get better and get back to it than he
could
and that's what he did
so now ask yourself is your life
dictated by luck
or cause and effect are you in control
or is it somebody else is someone else
in control
or is it you and if it's you
go build the life that you want because
there's nothing stopping you but you
there isn't a better way to live your
life there's no
right way and wrong way there is only
the way that gives you more energy there
is only the way that gives you
fulfillment
when you have those things when you're
fulfilled by what you're doing and it's
giving you the harder you pursue it it's
giving you more energy
you're on the right path as the greeks
would say
say the segola roma i can't believe i
messed that up
segolo doromo which means you're on a
good road and
that's what i want people to understand
like yes i teach
i preach a very specific path
but i don't think that it is a universal
path
and so the only universal path is to do
the things that give you fulfillment
and energy so if spending time with your
friends gives you that then you should
be spending more time with your friends
if dating gives you that then you should
be dating
so you don't need to want to be the best
in the world at something you don't need
to
want to make a lot of money you don't
need to want to be an entrepreneur like
all
they're literally just stand-ins they're
proxies
for fulfillment and energy creation
that's it so those are the punchlines of
what's the meaning of life and all of
that stuff
it is to do something that makes you
feel a
deep sense of well-being which i'll call
fulfillment
and something that gives you energy
where you're literally excited to attack
the day
as franz kafka said you are free
that is why you were lost look around
you
there are no guard rails on your life
the reality is that people have tried to
paint a picture for you that says that
there are certain things that are right
they've tried to paint a world for you
that has a path
well laid for it for you to follow go to
school
get good grades get a degree get a job
retire
that's the plan that everybody wants you
to believe
is really the plan but the reality
is that you are free to choose anything
you want the reality is you can go in
any path you want the reality is that
path
is an illusion the truth of life is you
can go anywhere you want you can be
anything that you want you can become
anyone you want to become
at the end of the day the choice is
yours at the end of the day you get to
construct yourself you get to decide
what it is that you want to believe as
long as you're not violating the laws of
physics
even physics is a game of maybe even
physics is uncertain and unknown
at the end of the day everything that
you get to do you get to choose you get
to create you get to build something
that you want to be
and in that that's where people get lost
they don't understand that the control
is theirs they're lost because they
think there's a path they think there's
a way forward
and emotionally it doesn't resonate
emotionally they're unable to
make it feel real because it doesn't
feel real they feel lost
they're unsure they don't know where to
go or who to become or even who
they are and that sense of being lost
comes from the freedom of being able to
choose anything you want
but no one told you that you could
choose
but as tupac shakur said reality is
wrong
dreams are for real
it's the dream that you want to focus on
the dream is your ability to construct
that path
the dream is you saying this is the way
that i want to walk the dream is you
saying all of this nothingness all of
this mass confusion all of this
probability
and uncertainty i am going to manifest
something real
and concrete and directional in my life
i
choose to be who i am i choose to be who
i become
i choose to build something with my
hands
to create something that has never been
seen before to do something that people
have never done before
to believe in things that other people
cannot see
that dream
is my reality that dream is what i'm
going to bring into existence
that dream is the thing that i believe
in
and in believing in that dream and
building that path and finding out and
deciding
who you want to be
for the first time you will find
yourself
in yourself becoming
so go become what you want to be
don't worry about walking somebody
else's path
here is the reality about money so the
reason that people chase it even though
i know you've heard a thousand times and
it is absolutely true
money can't buy happiness that if you're
chasing money the odds of you
ending up with some level of
dissatisfaction
is incredibly high but the reason that
people ignore that and the reason that
they keep chasing it the reason that i
myself
live the cliche of money can't buy
happiness is because money actually does
have power
now the thing that money lets you do the
thing that gives it that power the
reason that people will chase forever
and ever and ever is it is the great
facilitator now being a great
facilitator does not mean that it gives
you
the thing that you secretly want in your
life so here's the punch line about
happiness the goal of all of this the
goal of this game of
life that we're all playing it is not
money
it is not success it is entirely brain
chemistry it's entirely how you feel
about yourself
when you're by yourself it's about being
deeply fulfilled it's about being proud
of who
you are now those are all for me
synonyms it's the same thing which i'm
just going to
shorthand to fulfillment the thing
you're chasing is fulfillment
it's the only thing that doesn't sway
with the wind
so happiness in its typical definition
is very transient so i want to shift
people over to thinking about
fulfillment
fulfillment is often born of suffering
it's born of
not doing something you want to do it's
born of doing the hard things
being proud of yourself comes from that
being proud of yourself comes from
working your ass off to acquire a set of
skills
that by the way in and of themselves in
acquiring it you found that pleasurable
it's something that you're interested in
you've
hopefully crafted developed
built a deep passion around and in
acquiring those skills
in service of that thing that you love
and enjoy you're able to serve other
people
that's it that's the truth of happiness
that's the truth of the thing that is
going to give you that sense of
fulfillment that's going to allow you to
enjoy your life
money is never ever ever
in and of itself going to do that money
buys
cool money is able to give you those
temporary dopamine rushes of going and
shopping for something and getting it
and then it's cool
but then that coolness factor wears off
very rapidly
the flip side of that using that money
to build something that you believe in
that not only empowers you but helps
empower other people
that will help you develop long lasting
fulfillment so that's the real thing but
if you're doing something that isn't
making you a lot of money
but you're passionate about it you enjoy
the day today
and it's allowing you to build skills
that serve you and other people i
promise you if you had to choose between
the two which by the way you don't
but if you had to choose between the two
always and forever every single time
choose fulfillment tom am i going to
make it
do i have what it takes
when you look into my future can you see
me making it
and i'm going to cut to the chase for
all of you and you're going to mistake
what i'm about to say for good news
and then i'm going to tell you why it's
actually the worst thing i could tell
you
you all meet minimum requirements
you all meet minimum requirements
so whatever it is you want to do i'm not
going to say that it's going to be easy
for you
because you're ultra smart or something
you probably aren't
but everyone that i've encountered here
literally without
exception every single person that has
come up to me
and said something you meet minimum
requirements even you awkward
that have a hard time like making eye
contact even you guys i'm telling you
right now
you've got some you're going to have to
deal with but you meet minimum
requirements
now minimum requirements for what
for whatever you want now that sounds
great
right oh sh
tom said i can make it this is amazing
but all i've actually said is now
if you don't make it it's on you
and that's it there's nobody else to
blame
everything is your fault
everything people get the do part they
understand their actions should be
actions that take them towards what they
want to accomplish
but people often miss the most important
part
which is only to believe things that
move you towards your goals
and i see people every day
that tell themselves the story about
themselves that they are worthless
that they're meaningless that they're
pointless
that their friends and family would be
better off if they just died
so we have to find a way to construct a
narrative about ourselves
that empowers us that lifts us up even
though
even though we make mistakes even though
we fall down
even though we're never going to get
things right all the time and even
though terrible things happen to us
or maybe we do terrible things
but in that the erosion of the self
that's the danger the erosion of the
self that is the danger
and when i talk to people about the 80
20 principle 80 of the time you should
be focused on the things that you love
the beautiful things that you want to
bring to this world the beautiful things
that are already in the world
and 20 percent of the time you should be
kicking yourself in your ass
and saying you can do better
it's such a powerful idea
but the problem is when people get to
the 20 they forget
that it's only supposed to be 20 of the
time and that it's meant to be these
acute moments where you're pushing
yourself to be more to do more
it isn't so you can tear yourself down
that's
why you have to do and believe
that which moves you towards your goals
and if thinking that you're a worthless
piece of
moves you to your goals somehow then
fine do it but i can't literally
fathom a universe in which that would be
a logical way to move forward
so i'm going to give you the magic words
that you need right now to never fall
prey to that
believing i'm worthless does not serve
me
and i don't do things that don't serve
me
repeat that in your head every time
you begin to disparage yourself i want
to dispel a myth for you
it's the talent myth
it's the belief that some people were
just born with more than others that
some people are naturally gifted and
some aren't and
that's just the way the cookie crumbles
and whatever you're gonna be is
essentially determined by how you
started that your dna
is exactly your destiny i'm here to tell
you
right now that's [ __ ]
it's just not true it's not the truth of
the way that humans are designed as a
species were the ultimate adaptation
machine
the very thing that puts us at the top
of the pyramid
is our ability to adapt it is the fact
that the brain is plastic
that it responds to change it responds
to stressors
it responds to repetition
and repetition is a slave to obsession
as conor mcgregor said there's no talent
here this is hard work
this is an obsession you could be anyone
if you put in the time that's one of the
greatest athletes of our time telling
you that he's not the result
of genetics he's not the result of
natural gifts he hasn't been bestowed
something by god
he has shown up day after day in the
most
mundane of conditions on the cold days
on the hot days he put in the work
because he was obsessed with what he
could become and that repetition
that you need to actually gain a skill
follows that obsession
so in you right now right now today you
want to start building that obsession
you want to look at it like an
ember that can become a raging fire but
it needs your time
and attention it needs your time
and attention you've got to take that
interest you've got to take that
spark of desire and you've got to fan
the flames you've got to turn it into
that obsession and from that obsession
if you put in the work if you do the
things day in and day out the back
breaking work pushing through the pain
fighting through feeling like an idiot
fighting through embarrassment getting
up
brushing yourself off doing it again
practicing putting yourself at
somebody's feet and asking
what could i have done better not look
at the things you're doing well but look
at the things you're doing
wrong look at the things you're doing
poorly staring at your inadequacies
with no loss of pride because the only
thing you value in yourself is your
willingness to do that your willingness
to work your
ass off and as sylvester stallone said
i'm not the richest smartest or most
talented person in the world but i
succeed because i keep going
and going and going
and that's the secret as maya angelou
said
if you don't like something change it
if you can't change it change your
attitude
that's some of the best advice you're
ever going to hear
at the end of the day you should always
be trying to change the things that you
have
the ability to change there are
inevitably going to be things that you
can't change
but you're never helpless you're never a
victim in that moment you
still have the unbelievable ability
to choose to look at it in a new way to
choose to reframe it
and in that reframing you change
everything you don't just change your
own neurochemistry you're not just
changing the way that you feel
you're actually changing the way that
you're going to approach the problem
something that was
moments before something that seemed
impossible something that was breaking
your will to continue to
fight with a change in attitude become
something completely different
and as hans selye said adopting the
right attitude can turn a negative
stress
into a positive one and that game of
mental jujitsu is what it's about
that game of flipping something on its
head of turning something around of
seeing it in a new way
so that you can act in a new way
is how you make forward progress and
understanding that understanding the
need to take control of your perceptions
understanding that understanding your
need to change your perspective
that's how you begin to get ahead once
you understand your perspective is a
choice it is
not objective truth burn that into your
mind it is not objective truth the world
that you see around you
is simply the perspective through which
you see it all of life is a fun house
mirror and when you acknowledge that
when you understand that you're looking
at a distorted view of the way the world
is you realize that you can adopt
a different distortion you can adopt a
distortion that allows you to see things
more clearly that allow you
to see things in a way that empower you
and that should always be the first step
is figuring out not
what is not what you can change
but instead understanding what you need
to change it to
and understanding that that change comes
from inside you
it isn't a manifestation that you have
to make in the outside world first it's
a change you have to make inside
yourself it is a shift of perspective it
is simply stepping
to the side of what you're used to and
how you're used to seeing things and
understanding
that in reframing things you take that
negative and turn it into something that
builds you
up but you've got to choose
you've got to decide you've got to
believe
that you can do it but once you believe
that you can see things in any way that
you need to to reach your goals your
life will change forever
because you'll actually reach your goals
now i've got a special bonus skip from
tom on how to change your
identity that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that question of the
day
i want to know what's the number one
takeaway that you took from this video
that you're going to apply to your life
put it down the comments below and if
you made it this far in a video you're
still here watching you commit
you're promising to take action we don't
just watch a video here believe nation
we do something about it if that's you
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well because i want to
celebrate
you right now between me and the person
i want to be between you
and the person you want to be there is a
gap of skill set
and that's it but once you know your
mission
and once you believe that you can
accomplish anything you set your mind to
then you can do the extraordinary now
for me
getting out of that space of being lost
of not knowing what i wanted to do with
my life
it all came down to needing to earn
credibility with myself
in very small incremental ways
this is me 60 pounds ago and i knew if i
was going to accomplish anything in my
life i was going to have to get control
of my mind
now ironically there's two ways to get
control of your mind way number one is
directly going to the mind
which can be very scary can be very
daunting very ethereal
it's ephemeral it's hard to grab onto
it's hard to touch
but way number two is through the body
and so i decided that my kung fu was
going to be to get very good at
developing my body and in that process i
was going to learn about nutrition which
would allow me to help my mom and my
sister
in that process i was going to earn
credibility with myself
and earning credibility with yourself is
so important
do it in microwaves for me just showing
up to the gym every day
was a micro victory i said i was going
to do it and i did it now you have to
understand
i hate working out so for all of you
crazy people that get an endorphin rush
from running
i hate you all running for me
is like being stuffed into a meat
grinder there is absolutely nothing
pleasurable about it whatsoever so
whatever neurological thing you guys get
that you've been blessed with i have not
been blessed with that
so for me showing up in the gym sucks
eating a bowl of ice cream is awesome
and so getting to
getting to a better place for me
was a totally different journey
thank you
and what that was was just showing up
every day and putting in the work it was
reading about human metabolism and
understanding how what i eat
impacts my body it was earning a little
bit of discipline
every day knowing that well i did it
yesterday i can do it again today
it was not eating something that i
wanted to eat and most
importantly and if you're taking notes
write this down
it was about changing my identity
because at the end of the day identity
and values
drive behavior
preach
identity and values drive behavior so if
you want to make a change
you have to change your vision of who
you are you have to begin telling
yourself a different narrative
and the narrative you tell yourself
about yourself is everything
and if you tell yourself that you're a
scared undereducated kid from tacoma
whose family has never accomplished
anything
let me tell you what you will become a
scared
under-educated kid from tacoma who never
accomplishes anything because that's
what you believe
you tell yourself that story enough and
it will become real
but on the flip side you could tell
yourself a story of you're a learner
you learn faster than most people you're
willing to put in more work than most
people you're willing to read more books
than most people
you're willing to spend an inhuman
amount of time
every day improving your mind simply by
getting new ideas into the system
and that you will admit that you're
wrong faster than anybody else that you
won't let your ego get in the way
and you tell yourself that story over
and over and over so when somebody comes
and tells you how stupid you are
that you're just a dumb kid from tacoma
you go you're right that's amazing
thank you for pointing out that flaw
because now that i'm aware of it i can
improve it because i'm the learner
and once i switched my narrative to
being the learner it didn't matter where
i started
it only mattered where i was trying to
go and as long as i had that clarity
then i could execute because i believed
i could do anything i set my mind to
without limitation
if you want some motivation on how to
never give up check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i like micro failure
i like micro failure i hate macro
failure
like death of your business is bad
but
you